well the Las Vegas Raiders may have
followed up on last year's successful
draft with another here in 2020 if you
take a listen to the adjectives use to
describe this class Las Vegas is ready
to write a new chapter in the Raiders
success story you got faster we got
tougher and we got more competitive
those three words are music to the years
of Raider Nation Raiders found a
roadrunner in the draft
Henry rhymes is the fastest player in
the NFL he can literally fly his
basketball skills show you that now he's
gonna fly down the field scoring
touchdowns I've been I've been working
for this everybody's gonna love them
we're gonna be selling O'Henry t-shirts
in Las Vegas pretty soon you mean like
this one who wouldn't want one of these
stand in line in the Las Vegas Raiders
were a lot of people apparently didn't
want the Raiders second first-round pick
Damon Arnett he wasn't on anybody's
radar in the first round
except for this team and the Raiders
liked him a lot he's a modern-day weapon
a modern-day surprising first-round pick
we really don't care what anybody
outside our building saying we're just
we have one goal and that point in a
Super Bowl and at the end of the day
nothing else matters what matters will
unfold in Las Vegas this fall the
writers will line up and compete with
any team at least they shimmied in the
right direction we have the ability now
I think with our personnel to it that on
a weekly basis to attack wherever we're
playing and play aggressively where's
that music again writer nation did you
hear that it's coming and Chucky can't
wait can't wait to play in that Stadium
I'm so excited to move to Vegas and make
some friends and get this party started
you got no idea hey cue the music
all right exciting times